today on stick to football
congratulations to LSU the Tigers and
undefeated season national champions
we're gonna talk about the game get you
caught up on everything you missed with
player declarations and news and then it
is a mock draft Wednesday we wanted to
wait till on nationals after the
national championship game the Connor we
have a busy two and a half week stretch
ahead of us the college football season
is over and if it wasn't already draft
season it definitely is now yeah I mean
one more week less than a week of
declarations here so you have that going
on in the draft circle obviously an
awesome season for LSU a legendary
historic season for LSU jobber Oh coach
OH all the playmakers on that team and
that staff so it was really exciting but
this is when things really pick up for
us I mean we have a mock draft coming
your way where there are some changes
there are some risers and followers of
course we're gonna answer your draft on
draft questions but before we do any of
that Matt we got to talk about not only
the national championship but a lot of
news going around the NFL and college
football world right now yeah and you
listen to this Wednesday morning you can
happen to be our app at the NFL draft
stream and I have an article looking at
some of my guys that I thought showed up
and some guys who disappointed in the
national championship and what we're not
gonna spend a whole show on that because
I think that we too often live in a
microwave Society of we watch one game
and you want to over evaluate everything
and I had people last night saying that
Trevor Lawrence is good and you got
people who are saying you know the ACL
is not good or Christian Fulton's not
good we don't live in that role we live
in a role where you evaluate guys for
two three four years and then make a
decision on them so I don't want to get
super hot takee
hell I saw somebody saying that Joe
Burrell wasn't gonna be a good NFL
quarterback after last night so whatever
take you one you can find it on Twitter
this morning but I am continually
impressed by Joe burrow and I think it
would be funny to go back and listen to
the show right after the Texas game
where we watched that game in Austin and
then I went home and watched it again
and I just I had my head in my hands
watching that game it was like how do
you stop this guy and coach o mentioned
it last night the third and 17 throw
from Joe burrow and I remember sitting
with you and Melo and a bunch of our
listeners when that throw happened I
just threw my hands up it was like well
I
Texas fan we can't stop this guy that
Monday Joe burrow made it into the first
round of my mock draft and since then
it's just been a climb for him you know
beating Alabama beating Georgia 70
touched
excuse me sixty touchdowns this year
stuff it's the best season I've ever
seen for a quarterback and I think you
could say LSU beating seven top ten
teams this year whether they deserve
that ranking or not when they played
them you can say LSU just had one of the
best seasons we've ever seen for a team
I mean I think so when you look at it
this was so impressive whether it was
the schedule also the fashion that they
beat teams in Matt I think that counts
for something I mean this is a team that
when they needed to score over 40 points
they did it when they need a big
defensive stop they did it they blew out
some good teams even the national
championship when you look at the game
yes it was a slow start for LSU but the
second half it just felt like Clemson
was never fully could never fully get
themselves back in this game and that's
because of the the killer instinct when
you look at LSU Boro was taking shots
down the field to close out the game
they weren't just turning their backs
and handing the ball to Clyde Edwards
Hilaire and saying let's kill some clock
and pray our defense gets a stop against
Trevor Lawrence and Justin Ross and
Travis EDN and even when T Higgins came
back on the field so I think that counts
for something it really does and it was
an incredible season by the LSU Tigers I
know we're really happy for them Baton
Rouge is our favorite place we've ever
had a tailgate at the people there were
awesome to us and this is a very easy
football team to root for and now we
move on because it's not only gonna be
Jo burrows NFL career but it's gonna be
a lot of people surrounded by this LSU
program moving on to the NFL yeah ton of
underclassmen we'll wait to hear what
they decide but I do want a shout-out
before we move on
Patrick Queen and I say a Simmons if
you're looking for inside linebackers
whether it's this year next we'll see
what Queen decides to do those dudes are
the new prototype guys who can run like
that and can take over the middle of the
field I feel like the first half Isaiah
Simmons was probably the MVP of the game
the second half Clemson could not get
him in those matchups LSU did a
wonderful job scheming away from him
Patrick Queen for LSU was as impactful
in the second half of my opinion so I
want to shout out those two dudes it's
just having a fantastic game it's gonna
be one of
where you watch it 10 times because
there was just so much talent on the
field and you want to see those matchups
so again Congrats to LSU we're not gonna
spend the whole show on it because again
we don't want to over evaluate one game
but I do want to jump into some of the
news because a lot did happen Monday and
Tuesday this week that we want to talk
about AJ epinet as where we are as we
are recording this Tuesday morning he
has declared for the draft I think this
is notable for a couple reasons he is a
top 10 player on my board really has
been all year has a little bit of a slow
start this year but turned it on
amazingly once they got into the Big Ten
schedule but epinasty declares we're
still waiting for Tristan works so we'll
see what the Iowa guys and he may yet
announce while we're recording today if
he does we'll jump in with it but AJ
epinet I think and you guys will see
when getting the mock draft I really
like him I know we've had some
disagreements on this desk before
especially when Melos here about where
do you play him in the NFL I've compared
him to what we've seen this year from
Arik Armstead with the 49ers I think
could play defensive in he could play
defensive tackle he could play five
technique but his athleticism his length
and his ability to pair those things
together she's gonna make him really
really tough to block whether he's over
the tackle over the guard or in a gap
without a doubt I think it's it's one of
the players that there's gonna be a lot
of varying opinions on now I was really
excited for epinet so coming into this
year and I think it was a year of you
know some flash and great plays there
was definitely some slow weeks and I
think that had people wondering you know
what is his projection at the next level
so it's gonna be interesting for epinet
so you want to see how he works out you
want to see what kind of player he
projects to be at the next level in
terms of weight is he gonna come in
lighter at the combine and try to look
more athletic maybe he had 270 pounds
and and up some of those times or is he
gonna come in heavier anyway 285 and
show listen I'm gonna play on the
interior you know and be that kind of
pass rusher and listen that's not you
don't have to win one way we don't need
AJ epinet to be this you know five Tech
this nine wide kind of rusher we don't
need them to necessarily be Nick Bosa
Brian burns to be a good player that's
not what we're saying it's just that you
need to figure out what his best role is
at the next level but I
tell you this it's obvious that he's
gonna be a first-round pick Matt you and
I were talking about that before the
show
it's no secret and that these next
couple months is a huge chance for him
to raise that stock even further yeah
testing will be big for epinet now
another guy who announced his intention
right before the national championship
game was Trubel Hubbard a player that
just had a historic year a fantastic
year for Oklahoma State he announces
that he will be going back to Stillwater
so Oklahoma State is able to bring Chuba
Hubbard back and wide receiver Thailand
Walz who ended this year on injury but
quarterback Spencer Sanders and head
coach Mike Gundy gotta be pretty damn
happy to wake up on Tuesday morning and
realize that the band is back together
that trio might be the best in college
football next year with teams like Ohio
State breaking and new running backs or
receivers LSU's maybe breaking in a new
quarterback
Alabama's gonna have a new quarterback
and probably a new running back but
Oklahoma State's offense is gonna have a
lot of firepower next year they really
do and I think this was probably a
decision I think Thailand Wallace was
the beginning of Cuba Hubbard probably
sitting there and saying listen I don't
need to rush out now I believe he's been
there exactly three years so in one of
those years was a redshirt year so for
Hubbard this is a chance for all the
attention to be on him coming into next
year when you're filling out your
Heisman projections of course you're
gonna talk about Trevor Lawrence Justin
fields I completely get that but Hubbard
at times and I'm guilty of this too it
felt like the college football world at
times did not appreciate the greatness
this year that was Chuba Hubbard and
sometimes that could be because of your
program you're not an undefeated team or
a team hovering around for the playoffs
or a chance of the playoffs and next
year they come in with a clean slate and
for a chance to him to own that yeah it
is gonna be that's gonna be a magical
year if everyone can stay healthy
protocol on the state and I say that as
a Texas man like they're gonna be really
really good next year another player who
declared a this would have been a
surprise until Matt rule took the
Carolina Panthers head coaching job
James Lynch who was like Baylor's JJ
Watt basically yeah basically for 295
pounds the ginger giant this guy if you
watched Baylor this year and and I know
we had a lot of conversations about them
and be like man they don't mini NFL
prospects but they did have James Lynch
and he is a legit and
prospect here's a top 40 player on my
board Connor he is going to go right
into this interior D line mix and he is
going to push guys that you know I
really like Ross black luck I really
like Neville Gallimore those dudes just
got pushed down a little bit because
Jamie James Lynch coming into this class
he's going to push people that I think
he's better than Raekwon Davis who a lot
of people will know from Alabama you
know it's a three-year starter I think
James Lynch is just his motor is so much
fun and he gets push he has speed and
this is a really special guy who we're
not gonna see at the Senior Bowl unless
he has a degree I don't know about but
it is it is fascinating to watch him
play football he was phenomenal this
year thirteen and a half sacks three
forced fumbles he was the guy on the
Baylor defense that could take over
games for you up front and I think this
is a good decision by him to leave and
I'm with you Matt I think if Matt rule
had stayed rules the kind of guy that
can convince people to come back to the
program especially a player like Lynch
but when you look at it this is a good
decision his stock is hot right now
listen there's gonna be a time where
it's gonna be interesting to see if he
could sneak into round one of some of
these mock drafts and I think he's one
of the players will have circled for at
the NFL Combine because you've heard us
on the defensive line talent the
interior lion town we talked about
Derrick Brown Javon Kinlaw a lot and
Lynch is gonna find his way into the
conversation with the top group I think
maybe not on those guys level because
Brown is probably a top five top seven
player but the Lynch hype will really
take off now that he's officially in
yeah he's a he's just a really good
player he's like he's not gonna pass
Derek Brown he's not gonna pass Javon
Kinlaw but he might be right behind
those guys on this interior defensive
line class which is starting to look
really really good now another
announcement and you guys may have
missed it because during the national
championship game former Houston
quarterback the Eric King announces that
he's gonna enter the transfer portal I
just want to talk to Derrick is a guy I
worked in marketing before I worked a
bleacher report but it does not take a
marketing expert to tell you do not make
a major announcement during the biggest
college football game of the year you
save this do it Chuba hubbard do it five
o'clock well everybody's watching the
pregame show or do it today tomorrow
wake up boom fire off that tweet I
understand that you want to get in the
portal and it was interesting because
you know he sat out this year and there
was talking about his Dana Holgorsen
redshirting guys and then Derek Kings
family kind of gets involved now we know
officially he's entered the portal which
by the way does not mean he's leaving
Houston necessarily guys can enter the
transfer portal and not leave so it's
not a get ahead of ourselves
but Derek King mostly notable this
morning for not understanding when to
fire off that tweet maybe he did it on
purpose maybe Derek King doesn't like
the attention and the announcement had
to come out I think I would number one
of us laughing because we're sitting
there we're all live tweeting the
national title game we're watching all
the top prospects in the country and
just LSU cap off a historic season and
all sudden this comes across the Twitter
timeline and everyone's like wait what
like now at a time like this I think the
question people will have is what are
the landing spots for dr.king and I'll
be honest with you Matt I don't see the
door open at a ton of places that'll be
coming in and giving him the hey you're
the starter right he come here at this
point cuz it's late I said how much we
love Jamie Newman going to Georgia cuz
that's a fit that makes sense Jake from
leaves Newman's a very very talented
player that just honestly caught some
bad luck at Wake Forest this year with
the injuries around him so going to
Georgia it's a seamless fit and a guy
that should be handed the starting job I
loved the Eric King he was one of my
favorite college football players to
watch a year ago a little over a year
ago but I think right now it's not easy
for me to find a logical landing spot
outside of the Houston program we can
ask Melo about this one he's on the
Friday morning show with this again but
I saw someone ask him this last night he
said you should go to Texas and play
slot receiver and I think there's gonna
be some question with the Eric King
about okay if you try to transfer to
like you're not going to Alabama and
taking a quarterback job at least I
don't think and I don't think you're
going to LSU and taking a quarterback
job Oklahoma has a rattler they're not
bringing in another transfer quarterback
so I I think Jarrett King is more like
Kelly Bryant when he left where and it's
very similar guy left the program
transfers and there's a little bit of
hype a little bit of hoopla and then he
gets to Missouri or wherever dear King
ends up and you're kind of like oh well
yeah okay we remember
wasn't that good so I think with Jarrett
King he's an exciting player I was very
excited to see him this year in Dana
Holgorsen defense but didn't seem to
work out and we will be waiting to see
where he lands let's take a break come
back what we got more I got one more
thing I will get to here because I think
it's hilarious
Oh Cho Cinco has announced he will be
having a tryout for the XFL oh my god as
a kicker you know what I like it I've
watched his kicking videos they are not
bad
so no number one it's good for him but
it's even better for the XFL if the XFL
needed some kind of entertainment factor
Ojo Cinco is the guy to bring it you
know they're doing a pretty good job of
marketing that thing so we haven't even
seen any football yet but some of the
rule changes and everything pretty
pretty damn fun now we'll take a break
and when we come back the bengals are on
the clock and you guys knew who the pick
will be it is mock draft time all of the
college football games have been played
the evaluation season really starts in
earnest now the Shrine Bowl is going on
this week NFL PA Bowl is going on this
week next week will be in Mobile Alabama
and then a month after that we have the
NFL Scouting Combine so for us for me
Conor mellow this is our time when the
season's over we're gonna get an influx
of tape we're gonna have time because
tailgate tours over to dig in on these
prospects because of that not so much
because of one game but because of that
time to evaluate players we're gonna
start to see some changes in our boards
mine has already been updated a lot from
where it was two weeks ago the last time
I released one because of that more time
to evaluate players the one thing that I
don't need more time to evaluate is this
at number one overall the Cincinnati
Bengals will select Joe burrow
quarterback LSU this is the easiest
decision a lot of people want to fight
me on that be like not Andrew Luck was
people were saying RG 3 should be the
first pick ok this is the easiest
decision I've seen in my 10 years of
covering the draft Joe burrow to the
Bengals the Ohio kid comes home he's
gonna be the savior of this franchise we
heard Jim naggy talk about the
connections between Zach Taylor and Joe
burrows brothers the families have
already talked
you could just put this down in ink I
mean this is a no-brainer and I'll
piggyback off of that with another
no-brainer the Washington Redskins at
number two take chase young I know
people are out there spreading absolute
nonsense and [ __ ] that chase young
didn't show up against Clemson I don't
know what football game they watched I
think he had ten pressures just because
the guy doesn't have three sacks every
single week doesn't mean he didn't show
up and if you also watch a lot of teams
since chase young destroyed everyone in
his path for the first three months our
double-teaming him non-stop and he's
still generating pressure and forcing
bad plays so chase young is a great
football player yes you'd like to see
him maybe round out his game and when I
say that a lot of his wins are coming
with the speed rush which is great he
has an awesome speed rush and he has the
power but it'll be a little more
consistent I think once he continues to
develop and that's no knock on chase
young I'm just saying if you're looking
for anything that he needs to get better
at but this is such an easy selection at
number two for Washington it really is
and I think with with Chase young I
don't know people are watching if they
said he didn't show up but I can
remember not watching I'm an old man so
I can remember people saying things like
that about Nick and Joey Bosa about I
can remember it about Miles Garrett or
Bradley Chubb I think sometimes people
expect defensive ends to have a sack
every play just like wide receivers
can't drop a pass or corners can't have
a bad play in coverage I think sometimes
people just get a little bit too excited
number three and this is where the draft
starts the Detroit Lions are gonna have
a hard decision to make because you have
the entire class in front of you and I
think it would be smart of Bob Quinn and
Matt Patricia to answer their phone to
try to jump up drum up interest starting
really right now if they're on the road
at these all star games drumming up
interest in trading back for this pick
because there will be quarterback needy
teams wanting to move up now in mock
drafts right now we don't project trade
so I have the Lions standing here and
taking Isaiah Simmons and that might
seem early for him but he's number five
on my board and when you watch the Lions
play this year it's not a bad team but a
lot of their needs don't match up with
where the board is right now they need
like they could use another defensive
end opposite Trey flowers well there's
not one here but Isaiah Simmons is going
to give you coverage ability in the
middle of the field as we saw
against LSU he can rush the quarterback
he can stop the run the Lions
linebackers cannot cover so the isaiah
simmons comes in and really answers
every question they have at the
linebacker position i have no problem
with him going third overall I do think
ultimately this pick will be traded by
the Lions which will net them a lot more
assets especially the ideal for the
Lions is to flip to number five with the
dolphins because then you're only moving
to back yep and you're basically
assuring yourself that you're getting
either Isaiah Simmons or Jeff Okuda
which is pretty nice for them and would
help both would help them a lot and just
to be clear here Matt you know once
these mock drafts start getting a little
stale you know we'll mix it up with some
trades as we always do but we're
probably still a month away from that or
so we need at least a final draft order
right before we said all the
underclassmen yeah exactly so number
four the New York Giants this is pretty
easy for me this pick is Jedrek wills
get Daniel Jones and offensive line
listen Daniel jones definitely needs to
work on the fumbling problem it's a
significant issue but one way you can
maximize that is make sure he gets hit
less and if you upgrade your tackle spot
with the player like Jedrek wills I
think you're doing just that
you heard the Joe judge press conference
they want to be a tough team they want
to come out and punch teams in the face
that's the style Jedrek wills plays this
is a football team that they drafted a
running back at 2:00 in SE Quan Berkeley
you got to have an offensive line for
the guy to run behind I just don't see
the Giants going in any other direction
here maybe I'm wrong maybe things will
change but I think unless they really
hit it out of the park and free agency
they have to get another tackle they
really do and I think you can even look
at just the style of football that we're
gonna think they want to play in it's
hard with a new head coach coming in we
we don't really know that's what they
want to do yeah but that's what you
would expect and I you look at a guy who
was in New England and an alabama and
get a pretty good idea what he's gonna
want to do
Jedrek wills absolutely belongs in this
spot number five the Miami Dolphins
there is no drama here to talk about
Aloha as long as the hip is good he
should be the pick here maybe you
weren't like could Justin Herbert have
an amazing Senior Bowl week and jump
into the spot he absolutely could last
year at this time we were telling a lot
of people hate Daniel Jones to be a
first-round pick a lot of folks did not
believe it anyone
top ten justin herbert's in a similar
spot but I think as long as tua is
healthy this is a team that was giving
clear signals that they were taking for
this player nine months ago so I think
as long as we're getting positive
reports on tua we're probably gonna see
a Ryan Fitzpatrick to a tongue about alo
a quarterback room next year in Miami
and don't forget this team they have two
other picks in the first round so they
can be aggressive like Connor said trade
up to three the Giants won't trade a
four because Dave gentlemen refuses to
trade but I think the Dolphins are one
of the most logical teams to trade up in
this draft and even better if you're a
Dolphins fan listen to this show you
have two twos so you can probably go
from five to three from both the
second-round picks you keep all your
first rounders which is the most
important thing for them number six the
Los Angeles chargers this is another
team that needs offensive line help and
these guys are gonna come off the board
fast and furious I'm going Andrew Thomas
here you know some people might think
this is a little high for Thomas but
Matt how many years did we see offensive
tackles you know come off the board
earlier than expected I think we even
saw it last year when you look at you
know somebody like Caleb McGarry
is an interesting one the Year Mike
McGlinchey went to the Niners and that
wasn't a bad choice I'm just saying
these guys go earlier then you expect so
six the Chargers Andrew Thomas he's a
really really good run blocker I still
like him in pass protection I don't know
what's gonna happen with their
quarterback situation with Phillip
Rivers if he's gonna be back or not if
he is you got to protect him if he's not
you got to protect the next guy they
have a good stable of running backs
there even if they lose Melvin Gordon I
love Austin Eckler and I think this is
just a no-brainer here because the
Chargers this has to be the Giants the
Chargers the Browns the Jets the Jaguars
these are teams that are just gonna be
gunning this offseason to fill their
trenches and somebody is not going to be
a winner because there's just not enough
guys right I think we'll tackle in
quarterback we see a bit of a race to
fill those spots in the top ten because
a lot of teams need quarter I mean the
Chargers need a quarterback day but they
also need an offensive tackle so if you
don't like the quarterbacks on the board
go tackle here number seven the Carolina
Panthers they are starting over David
Tepper giving Matt rule autonomy really
to run this football team when I look at
them I still think the Panthers need a
quarterback Cam Newton's contract
situation is sticky he's off
been hurt often over the last year and a
half so I'm projecting them to move
forward with Justin Herbert and I've
said before there's a lot to like about
this player he has sighs he and our
friend Chris Simmons you say all the
time size is a trait Herbert has a lot
of it he has arm strength he has
mobility he can get outside the pocket
and make plays he's agile enough to pick
up yards in the pocket breaks down know
what you don't like is he gets stuck on
his first read sometimes and there are
others where he's just a little
inconsistent throw into the middle of
the field but I do believe Herbert has
enough traits then he's gonna go top ten
whether we like it or not I think it's
time to just accept the fact that he's
gonna be an early pick in this draft the
Panthers need a quarterback I think your
hope is that mat rule who has some
experience coach in that position can
bring in a staff and could put a support
system around Herbert they have crushed
McCaffrey they have DJ more they've
curse Samuel hopefully you could put
enough of a team around Herbert that you
can maximize the gifts that he does
bring to the table and it's gonna be
interesting the next mock draft shall we
do because we're gonna hear so many so
many you know rumors and buzz and
nuggets about Herbert at the Senior Bowl
there's gonna be a lot of takeaways from
how he is in practice and I think this
mock draft you're gonna see a shift in
the quarterback so it's just gonna
solidify where they already are number
eight the Arizona Cardinals they get the
best wide receiver it's gonna be
interesting with CD language they Judy
he's the best receiver in the draft I
like CD a lot I really really do but I
think for Arizona this will be their top
grade and wide receiver it fits their
offense to it see Gerry Judy at eight
overall Kyler Murray quietly played very
very well this year he really had a
great rookie season
I thought Kliff Kingsbury actually
exceeded expectations in his first year
for a rebuilding Arizona team Chandler
Jones had a million sacks like he always
does but this is a team as Larry
Fitzgerald gets older they needed number
one for the future in this offense and
Jerry Judy is that guy yeah and you know
there has been a lot of talk about CD
land versus Jerry Judy and my concerns I
don't have a team take a CD Lance
awesome now I've said this a lot with CD
lamb most of his catches are crossing
routes middle of the field which that's
okay he's really good at it he's
physical I love his catch radius I love
how he is after the catch but when I see
a receiver who I question their speed
and they're constantly running crossing
routes I get
a little bit worried and I think that's
why the combine is gonna be big for CD
land because we do want to see how fast
he is how loose his hips are want to
watch him run a full route tree
something he really didn't do at
Oklahoma so that's why Jerry Judy's
still number one overall for me at
receiver number nine the Jacksonville
Jaguars could they really get this lucky
Jeff Okuda is sitting on the board at
number nine you lose Jalen or amz you
just replace him with a quieter version
of the same dude six foot one two
hundred pounds jeff Okuda has everything
you look for in a star corner prospect
size speed instincts toughness ball
skills there's a reason that we have all
set is hosting the show he's one of the
best corners we've ever evaluated
sometimes people do things and they just
make it look easy and we forget how
great they are because of it that is
Jeff Okuda he makes everything in the
corner position look easy I'll tell you
if he falls tonight I hope the Jets
trade up for him
because he has no business falling to
nine but the way the board falls it
makes you kind of believe it can happen
it's crazy you know three we see these
four quarterbacks this happens every
year with the quarterbacks and then
Isiah Simmons has just been a rocket
ship with this stock and all the
offensive lineman people are gonna reach
on them and that's fine there's a need
there and chase young he's a great
player so when the odd man out is is
Jerry Judy or Jeff Okuda that's how it
goes so it's it's gonna be fascinating
to me and then after this pick is when
the board starts to take a turn but ten
the Cleveland Browns I'm not that
confident he's gonna be in the draft but
until he says he's not I'm putting him
here and that's triste and worse there
is a lot of buzz around Tristan worse
whether it's that he want he made a
promise to get his degree and finished
school or it's tough for me Matt I think
with works he feels like a lock as a top
15 pick that's a lot of money to pass up
but live your life do your thing we'll
see the decision he makes the fact
that's gone on this long shows it's
become a lot more difficult of a
decision than he expected
but for the Cleveland Browns we said it
after the Kevin Stefanski hire this is a
team that needs offensive line help and
they get the last of the top three
offensive tackles here right before the
Jets at 11 would pounce on them yeah I
think Tristan Worf
you know I don't I have no idea what
he's gonna do and I imagine it's a very
tough decision for him for his family if
he enters I think he'll be a top ten
pick number 11 your New York Jets and
I'm probably gonna just make some
friends in New York today I think oh I
do not have them going CD lamb because
it's a mock draft which for me I try to
do what I think the teams will do not
what I would do and so I am NOT going CD
lamb here not going Henry rugs nah going
t Higgins I'm going to H a up in esse
and I know there's gonna be people
throwing things at their radio or
however you listen to this run faster on
the treadmill if you're mad at me but
looking at Joe Douglas I cannot see this
man prioritizing the wide receiver
position in round one so in a real draft
the Jets would probably trade back in
this spot or like you said counter they
probably would try to trade up to
jumping a get at Jeff Okuda or one of
the tackles in this draft we can see
them do that but at 11 if this is how
the board Falls
if all three offensive tackles are off
the board if Jeff accout is off the
board I think you have to look at a
japanesse and say okay does he fit Greg
Williams defense a great way is smart
enough to work guys into his scheme it's
not a true four three or three four
where we see every team running
basically nickel seventy-five to eighty
percent of the time now I think epinasty
putting him next to Quinn and I know
people have flashbacks like we've seen
this show before
I think these players are different and
I think this front office is different I
think Greg Williams is different so I
know it's not gonna be the pick that
gets Jets fans excited but I'm trying to
be realistic here not make you guys feel
good about your day I absolutely hate it
but I also don't think you're wrong I
don't think this team will take a wide
receiver at 11 I think they'll look they
have three picks on day two they have a
high second rounder and they have two
high third rounders because they have
the New York Giants third-round pick so
I think they'll wait till then to take
one of the wide receivers but the reason
I hate it Matt is that you need to if
you're not getting a CUDA you need to
figure out a way to help Sam Darnell
like they have guaranteed money tied to
Henry Anderson they have Quinn and
Williams they have Steve money tied to
Steve McClendon they have Nathan Shepard
who played really well I
hope that epinet shows up to the combine
at like 265 and everyone's shocked and
it's like oh he can line up out wide and
rush the quarterback then I'd be all in
on that pick yeah it wouldn't surprise
me if he does that or I mean he might
come in at 295 and he's a detachable you
know everybody said yeah never mind you
know but I wanted to do this because I
do believe this could happen if the
three tackles are gone if worse had been
there I would've drafted him but if the
three tackles are gone the Jets find
themselves in a position that is tough
and I know in a lot of mock draft
Monday's will it's the oval wide
receiver
Jose Aldo Singh is not doing that so
it's - I think it's time it's middle of
January it's time start getting
realistic with these instead of like oh
well here's the biggest need we'll just
throw a player in there so all that said
you now get to be on the clock with the
Raiders listen it's all true and I'm
glad that you brought up here is the
biggest need and a player that they
would like and the Raiders would be
doing dances in their war room if they
get CD lamb because this is the type of
wide receiver that I think Jon Gruden
would love to have in that room I think
it would be very interesting between
lamb or rugs because Gruden has made it
very clear they need deep speed and if
that's the case you go get Henry rugs I
also could see this being a team that
makes a contract offer to Robby Andersen
in free agency because they tried to
trade for him a couple times with the
New York Jets
so the Raiders are interesting Jon
Gruden has been vocal about them needing
help in that wide receiver room and if a
guy like CD lamb falls to them at 12
there's no isaiah simmons on the board
there's no aj epinet support
there's no Jeff Okuda on the board the
quarterbacks are gone if they wanted to
take a swing and develop a guy behind
Derek Carr I just can't go any other
direction other than CD lamb at 12 for
the Raiders which i think is just a
great win for them it is a huge need for
them it's a very very good pick number
13 the Indianapolis Colts Jordan Love is
my pick here and I'll tell you I do not
have him graded in the first round
that means absolutely nothing because if
a team falls in love with him and the
Senior Bowl next week he's gonna be
drafted early and like we've said with
Justin Herbert like we just said with
the offensive tackles some positions are
so important guys are gonna get drafted
earlier especially because of need
Jordan love could be picked 12 and it
wouldn't surprise me he'd be pick
13 here to the Colts 14 to the Bucs I do
think there's a strong chance that he
goes first round with teams fall in love
with his arm strength his mobility you
watch the 2018 tape Matt wells had him
looking like Pat mahomes in watch 2019
and you're like what the hell happened
he lost his receivers he lost his coach
I'm not trying to make excuses for the
guy I'm just telling what goes on in
these scouting conversations of Matt
Jordan love looked really really good in
2018 which is why we talked him up a lot
headed into the season fell apart a
little bit this year I thought he was
really forcing things trying to make
something happen with the bad cast of
characters but we've seen this show
before
Josh Allen did the same thing of Wyoming
still went top 10 I think Jordan love
next week of the Senior Bowl his climb
is gonna start to where he ends up a top
15 pick I mean nobody helped Daniel
Jones out as last year at Duke we see
the show year after year with
quarterbacks and sometimes they fail
miserably and sometimes they pan out I
think with both Josh and Daniel Jones
Josh Allen and Daniel Jones were we're
still waiting to see we've seen
rollercoaster games week in and week out
from them some great some bad and I
think Jordan love I will never sit here
and laugh at someone when they suggest
the quarterback will go in the first
round that you wouldn't expect no I'll
never do it because number one joy and
love is the traits to go in round one
number two this happens every single
year and he's one of the guys that will
be watching every single rep closely
from mobile so 14 the Bucs they're
sitting here no Jordan love
no Justin Herbert no two atong of AI
Aloha and definitely no jobber oh that's
a pipe dream for them and we don't know
what they're gonna do with Jameis
Winston this offseason I'm not a
believer that it's a lock that he's back
I want to be very clear about this right
now I don't think they're gonna extend
them long term and I don't know if we'll
play on the franchise tag I don't even
know if they want to pay Matt the
franchise tag number the Bucks are
fascinating to me and I don't have the
solution for quarterback right now
that's going to be its own segment
someday so I'm going with Derek Brown
the best player on the board right now
and if you're a Bucs fan and you don't
like that
listen Dara has no business falling
outside of the top ten he's here at 14
you have Derrick brown and freakin
Veta baya upfront defensive line I'll
tell you who's gonna be sitting there
smiling Todd Bowles who might be the
future coach of this team one day when
Bruce Arians retires yeah that's a lot
about Grant helpit that he's been
slotted in this spot all year and it's
not to pick Derek Brandes by far BPA 15
the Denver Broncos I believe that they
have their guy Andrew Luck I think they
have a number one receiver in Cortland
Sutton we'll see what Noah fan becomes I
love Dalton rising there on defense the
team there's gonna be some turnover but
I did not have a player graded highly
enough on defense to draft here we'll
see what happens with Chris Harris jr.
he's a free agent but I'm gonna give
them what I think they lack on offense
and that has a home run hitter so Henry
rugs the third from Alabama and his four
to speed be stretching the field for
drew Locke who has a very very strong
arm this is the type of matchup like
always got his guy now let's see if he
can build the team around them like he
did back when he had Peyton Manning I
think Henry rugs stretches the field
really well for the Broncos next year
yeah him in Cortland Sutton that would
be electric
it really would I would love to watch
that and I really believe in you know
investing in players around your lock
and seeing what you have in him and it's
gonna be very interesting with them
making offensive coordinator change as
well to see hopefully more jumps that
you lock takes plays that's where the
higher pass rumors all about big
explosive plays ya know he likes to do a
draw on third and eight so we'll see
about that
all right 16 the Atlanta Falcons Jeff
glad he may be the biggest riser in this
mock draft here the more gladney tape I
watched the more I like I think he's
gonna run at least the four-four he
might be faster he might be in the four
threes he sticky he's got good length he
plays the football in the air is
something that a lot of young corners
don't do I love Jeff Gladney I think the
Falcons absolutely need to take a corner
in round one and they need to do it they
need to not even think about it because
after this they're all gonna come off
the board right away ya gotta go corner
here if you want one
especially with pulse energy but go back
to school right let's take a break 17 to
32 coming up right after this
we are back the Cowboys are on the clock
and when you're gonna rip through the
second half of this draft the Cowboys
are 17 defensive line Javon Kinlaw we'll
see what happens with their 26 free
agents but I feel like this is a best
player available they could go so many
spots here receiver corner safety but I
think interior d-line it's gonna be very
very important for this defense moving
forward yeah that's a no-brainer Kinlaw
should have a really really big week he
really should he's gonna win a lot of
one-on-ones 18 the Miami Dolphins they
got to uh now get him a wide receiver
Justin Jefferson you saw what this guy
did all season and this guy I mean low
key Matt besides Joe burrow this guy
might have been the best player in the
college football playoff honestly well
and then Jamar chase as well it's hard
there's so many good players on LSU at
this point
Justin Jefferson great route runner he's
got a great catch radius he's just a
reliable wide receiver you saw what he
did after the catch this is a no-brainer
him and Devante Parker would be your
future wide receiver duo in Miami number
19 the Las Vegas Raiders they went wide
receiver earlier in this draft here they
have to go linebacker we know the two
biggest needs on this team she was no
matter who's on the board where they
fill them but I'm going kenneth murray
from oklahoma may be forgotten about a
little bit as a junior who declared but
man he had an amazing two-year run at
oklahoma yes i lined to sideline speed
and I've said before I say Simmons is
like he's a predator I even know what
position the guy plays Kenneth Murray is
more like your prototypical linebacker
with speed coverage ability he stops the
run very well you go get his game
against army in 2018 where he like 25
tackles so Kenneth Murray to the Raiders
to finally solve their problems in the
middle of the field I love it I think
Kenneth Murray has you know well earned
a spot in the top 20 with how he played
this year and he's gonna test
off-the-charts number 20 Jacksonville
Jaguars they got really lucky in the top
ten Jeff Okuda falls to them that's a
home run pick now you got to wonder
what's gonna happen with Yannick and
gawk where they gotta trade him for
picks are they gonna give him a
long-term extension I'm gonna stick with
LSU here and go with edge pass rusher
Kayla Vaughn chase on whether they lose
in Gok way or not I think we you saw
what this guy did in the championship
game he flies off the edge
kind of reminds me of Brian burns I
don't think he's as complete as Brian
burns was coming out of the draft and
that's why he's in the 20 range rather
than the top 10 range but I think for
Jacksonville these two pieces would be
basically a defense fully rebuilt and
restocked yeah I think with chase on the
biggest questions will be injury you
know he's a redshirt sophomore who were
projecting to declare but he has been
banged up and he was a little bit slow
to get started this year once he did I
mean just in the Cotswolds playoffs I
mean he was dominant which you know I
don't if you remember with Cleveland
Ferrell first jumped on the scene it was
like oh the Colorado playoffs Scout was
unstoppable he went back to school ended
up the number four pick in the draft so
we'll see what Chaisson does with his
decision coming up he's got two days as
you're listening to this 21 the
Philadelphia Eagles they need a wide
receiver yellow
Nelson Aguilar is per agent and not that
good al Shan is my guy but he's been
hurt so much and he's getting to that
Plateau we didn't see any production
from the rookie class I mean Greg Ward
was there dude but we're still waiting
for the rookies to acclimate to get out
of the field and make something of it
but I'm gonna go with T Higgins here and
I know a lot of Eagles fans have been in
my mentions and and be like don't we
then we just draft this same guy last
year and I don't think so when I look at
Higgins I think he has a little bit more
speed he has a little bit more
separation ability than jjr Sager
Whiteside who was more of a possession
guy so when I look at Higgins and I
think we saw it Monday night his ability
to separate he can make things happen
over the top I mean JJ he was like a
four six guy I don't think Higgins will
I think he'll be a low four guys but you
saw it on the explosive run 36 yards
finish it with power the block down the
field which should have been called a
penalty but was I love the way Higgins
plays football it's unfortunately he got
hurt because I think once that happened
the Clemson offense really fell off a
cliff a little bit but I like Higgins
catch radius is their body type is on
point and I think he's faster than him
were giving him credit for 22 Buffalo
Bills they need a big bodied wide
receiver and a lot of the guys have come
off the board but ylvis' Cascino is
still here I mean he runs like a running
back we've seen him stretch the field
vertically we've seen him play a wildcat
on jet sweeps he does a little bit of
everything Chanel for Josh Allen John
Brown had a great year they like Cole
Beasley in the slot there they have some
pieces for him
but they desperately need to get a big
target for their young quarterback and
Chennault is the best one on the board
right now yeah a little bit of a run at
receiver and I think we will see this
happen in late April as well and it's
unfortunate because a lot of teams the
end of round one need a receiver 23 the
New England Patriots if they don't sign
a hunter Henry and free agency which
I've heard a lot of agents are
speculating about already it's like ah
AJ Green a hunter Henry we're going to
the Patriots well that makes sense if
they don't make those moves to move it
right typical Patriots right number 23
this work Cole commits goes man he is
he's it for me a tight end he can do
everything he can block dominates the
middle of the field the catch radius is
huge this year he broke his collarbone
so the numbers aren't gonna be
impressive so if you google him don't
look at the stats go check out some of
the the game tape if you can find it
Cole commit is exactly what this team
needs in the middle of the field whether
it's Brady or Stidham or whoever you
know dak Prescott as I think Sean said
what is man at quarterback next year
they need Cole commit this offense is
not the same without a Titan in the
middle of the field oh goodness
Phillip Rivers Pat mahomes who knows
who's gonna write it for the people
probably just here find a way to trade
up for Joe burrow which I was laughing
at somebody that asked you what would
the trade have to be for the Bengals to
move out of number one yeah somebody was
like how about 12 and Derek Carr it's
like are you come on come on guys I do
like the endless hope yeah yeah I don't
I mean Pat mahomes that's the only trade
that would get them out of Joe borough
right now 24 but you New Orleans Saints
Ameri not I don't know I'm going with
one of your guys corner backs EJ
Henderson I listen I think Henderson has
been up and down but I think he's a
really really athletic corner that can
continue to develop here and the Saints
they need a number two corner they
really do you kind of saw it in the
playoffs we've talked about this show a
lot how they needed a number to wide
receiver as well I just feel more
confident in them finding that guy
elsewhere whether it is later in the
draft most likely because there are
gonna be a lot of good players in that
spot and we've seen players transition
that New Orleans offense so easily so
for me you keep the run on corner going
here before your Sol and you
CJ Henderson yeah and I think the same
sir like you said they're in a thern a
unique spot both quarterbacks or free
agents actually take some Hill is a
restricted free agent they're gonna
bring him back they only have five picks
in this draft so I feel like they have
to prioritize and for me corners always
give me more important wide receiver
because they just had one of the most
prolific offenses and NF in the NFL and
and we're still waiting for a number two
receiver to develop maybe TRACON submit
takes that step but they pick again at
88 overall and then at 120 the depth of
receiver and the strat is much better
than the depth at corner and smart teams
are gonna notice that and I think we see
teams jump on corners here which is
exactly where I'm going at 25 with the
Minnesota Vikings it worked when you
drafted Stefon Diggs bring in little Big
Brother trevone Diggs he can be what
really I mean what they hadn't Xavier
roads before somehow he was like I'm you
know the monster talent right I mean
it's just horrible what has happened
here but Siobhan Diggs one thing you can
do is run six - Turner pass he can run I
think his technique is role but that
Vikings defense it's a pretty easy
transition from what Alabama does to
what the Vikings do I think big Diggs
makes a lot of sense here it's a little
bit of a reach for me but we've seen
that run at this position and I don't
have any offensive lineman valued in
this spot I don't have any quarterbacks
value in the spot which would be
interesting with Cousins entering a lame
duck season
but Diggs makes a lot of sense for the
Vikings but without a doubt I mean when
you look at it Diggs Tyrell you know
those are guys that are gonna fit the
profile here for the Vikings and they'll
desperately desperately need to grab a
corner so 26 the Miami Dolphins this is
their third pick so they've gotten to
a-- they've gotten justin Jefferson and
now they flip to the other side of the
ball to make Bryan Flores happy and that
is pass rusher from Penn State yeet or
gross Matos
and I think when you look at gross Matos
he fits in Florez defense very well I
still think this is an ascending player
and when you watch gross Matos this year
he has times where he could take over
the game and he can make tackles look
foolish and he has times where you're
wondering where he is and that's the
life of a pass rusher it happens but I
think his projection at the next level
is a high end starter at a premium
position
and I think Miami would their last
first-round pick would be all over that
yeah and with Miami you know they're
they're gonna be a base three four team
so he has the right size and speed to
rush off the edge
number 27 the Seattle Seahawks Jadeveon
Clowney is a free agent they would like
to keep him but if they can't and maybe
even if they can edge is in need here LJ
Collier did nothing in his rookie season
Terrell Lewis fits the body prototype
that they want six five 260 he we're
gonna see him at the Senior Bowl next
week I think he's going to go off in
ways that probably make him unavailable
27 overall because of the premium in
that position the biggest questions with
Trey Lewis our injury history people at
Alabama for three years now I've been
telling me how special this guy is it's
just a matter of getting him on the
field consistently to unlock those
talents if that happens for him I think
you'd be a very special pass rusher so
if clown he's back you got to stud speed
rushers and they both bring power if
clown he's not back this is your guy
that you earmark to replace him yeah I
think what Lewis once again I mean he
could put on a show when he's right but
Alabama there are scouts in the league
that will have concerns taking banged-up
Alabama players because we've seen it
bite a lot of teams in the past and it's
just something that it's gonna be
interesting to keep an eye on 28 the
Baltimore Ravens here Donovan people's
Jones I would have liked the Ravens to
get one of those edge guys that just
went off the board I would have loved
them to get Kenneth Murray that's not
happening here so get a big bodied wide
receiver for Lamar Jackson and you sit
here and you google people's Jones and
you say this guy had 34 catches for 438
yards this year how is he a first-round
pick he's a top-flight player a talented
talented player and he showed up against
a very good secondary in Ohio State he's
quarterback held him back all year the
former five-star recruit loaded with
talent he'll be better at the next level
and I think when you look at how
people's Jones and Hollywood Brown
complement each other this Baltimore
offense can take an even bigger step
with that much firepower at wide
receiver next year
Baltimore's a tough team because I'm a
Jew Donohue a free agent but there's not
an edge here that fits that mold of
rusher an exact bound to be interesting
but they're very different guys a middle
linebacker I think
little early for Malik Harrison so they
do get in a spot where this would
probably be a trade back in or maybe
even James Lynch yeah
maybe our guy James Lynch it actually
makes sense with Michael Pierce being a
free agent number 29 the Tennessee
Titans Jarrick Henry's a free agent Ryan
Tannehill suffer agent and I am watching
this closely to see which guy gets the
franchise tag
I think they what tanning Hills 32 I
think they want to lock him up for three
or four years Derek Henry's run the last
I mean really last year and a half has
just been historic what he's done in the
playoffs it's been amazing but if he
they are not able to keep him running
back becomes a gigantic priority for
this team the offense runs through the
backfield so I'm gonna give them JK
Dobbins this might be pessimistic of me
but I could see Derek Henry at what is
he 26 years old getting a contract offer
that the Titans just don't want to match
for a guy who's had so many carries in
high school college now the NFL would he
had 303 carries this year he's already
had 800 carries in his NFL career so I
think that you have to be aware of that
we talked about this a couple shows ago
love Derrick Henry will happily admit
how wrong I was about him succeeding but
I think you have to be smart and
evaluate this with your head not your
heart and with JK Dobbins he's gonna
bring a pass catching element to the
table that Derrick Henry does not only
18 catches this year for Derrick Henry
so I think JK Dobbins would even open up
this offense a little bit more I hope
they find a way to get it done I really
do and I think when you look at it with
Derrick Henry just turned 26 so and I
know the mileage is high but I love his
fit in that Tennessee offense and I'll
say this if they don't and they make the
hard decision
you get JK Dobbins I bet he has 1,300
yards as a rookie I do I think it's in
right tackle is a sneaky need for them
because they did not pick up Jack
Conklin's fifth year so this could be a
spot for like meki Becton this could be
a spot for let me pull up my list here
this could be a spot for you know Austin
Jackson Josh Jones Isaiah Wilson I have
four offensive tackles sitting there at
39 40 41 and 44 overall so I wouldn't
sneak on right tackle if they can keep
Derrick Henry are you just lower on Trey
Adams because the medical
shoes yep yep and I thought he didn't
move as well this year yeah stiff to me
which you got a guy with back issues and
then he looks stiff
I think senior Bulls gonna be really
important for him because we're gonna be
able to put him in that little bubble
like I like to say and just watch him
move and see how well he handles space
and speed and and how how stiff or not
stiff he looks and I'm glad he's going
because of that because it's as an
offensive lineman it's risky when you're
in those one-on-ones it's not an easy
place to showcase yourself all the time
so I do think medically the medical
problems keep Adams out of round one I'm
really curious to see is he a top around
to you guys he around five guy because
of those issues so we'll keep an eye on
that thirty the Green Bay Packers a lot
of wide receivers are gone I'm gonna go
with KJ hammer here I think his speed in
this offense you have Davante Adams his
route running hammers deep speed Aaron
Rodgers this Green Bay team has been
phenomenal this year that defense is
incredible they have a great run game
with Aaron Jones they hit a home run
drafting L from Jenkins last year there
is not an offensive lineman for them to
take in this spot as some of those guys
are getting older in that group so take
Hamlet might be one of the most
underrated players in this entire of
giraffe class right now he really might
be and I've talked a lot about this with
you guys that when you look at it this
receiver class eats a stack a lot like
the receivers so I have KJ ham lured
Justin Jefferson Gabe Davis from UCF
Jalen Rieger Brandon I uke like I have
those guys all kind of together right
now
Donovan people's Jones we're just
waiting for more film waiting for more
opportunity to evaluate them we're gonna
see I uke in Mobile next week so there's
just a lot of guys that are kind of
stuck there together where the Packers
can probably get the best of like you
would call this tier 3 at receiver and
and what they really need is they need
speed they need someone who can help and
stretch the field and I think hammer can
definitely do that number 31 the Kansas
City Chiefs
I'm gonna go AJ Terrell here and I know
a lot of people who watch Monday night
are probably like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
AJ Terrell is better than he showed last
night I think he got put in a situation
against a receiver in Jabbar Chase who
is just a free
show and he you know what he panicked he
didn't play his best football I actually
wonder if AJ Terrell goes back to school
to try to work on this but man I really
like him I liked him last check remember
watch the Trey Trayvon Mullen I'm
thinking like AJ channels gonna be
pretty good player he has length and
it's funny in the first quarter
everybody was like you're too low on
this guy you got to get him up
by the end of the game people are like
why do you have a top 40 grade on this
guy so it is crazy cuz in in the first
quarter you saw the length the ball
skills you know he had a great pass
plate break up in the first quarter
there are definitely you know there's
gonna be some bad on his tape I think
with Clemson they have no safety help
which I don't know if that guy talked
about on the broadcast last night or not
but they have no safeties and guys like
a.j get put out on an island and you
know what you're gonna lose that every
now and then he's not Derrick Stingley
jr. I'm sorry but he is a very good
player the Chiefs in this spot should
honestly try to trade back they have
needs a corner linebacker interior
offensive line they're gonna need
another running back at some point and
they don't have many draft picks so a
trade back is probably what happens but
if we're stuck here then I think AJ
Terrell he's the best corner on the
board by far 32 San Francisco 49ers your
49ers Matt this is where Grant Delpit
finally gets out of the green room makes
his way up the stage it's a long wait
for Delpit but let's just call it like
we see it even though we've stood by
Delpit this year it was not a good year
for grant Delpit it was not a good year
I don't know if he was hurt and playing
hurt throughout it I just I can't figure
it out I'm gonna go back and watch the
sophomore year tape and then I'll finish
the rest of this year's tape and
probably find common ground somewhere in
between the Niners need a safety and I
still believe grant Delta is a very
talented player that will thrive under
Roberts ala in this defense where you
have a great front you have some players
and a veteran in Richard Sherman that's
not gonna let you slack off right there
if there's a landing spot that can get
the most out of grant Delpit number one
him being picked 32nd that's called
being humbled and we don't know if the
Niners are gonna win the Super Bowl
but if he's picked outside the top 20
that's being humbled and I do think
they'd
maximize his talent and this would just
be such a good fit for each side I would
be pretty happy with this
if Tchaikovsky tart could stay healthy
man you have grant tell Pitt and Robert
Stella's defense I mean he he's gonna
use him like a Jamal Adams like James
like a camp Chancellor so he's gonna put
him in some really really good fits so
love that pic let us know what you guys
thought
leaving your Apple Apple podcast review
on my said a chance goodness leave your
Apple podcast review tweet us at stick
to football instagram smoke signals tell
us the next week and mobile that you
hate it if you want a lot of ways to get
a hold of us we come back we're gonna
ask you your questions in a little
segment we like to call draft on draft
it is draft on draft time don't forget
you can ask these questions in person at
draft picks Tap Room in Mobile Alabama
Monday and Wednesday of Senior Bowl week
that's next week 7:30 p.m. you don't
have to get there early get there 7:30
come in tabs probably be open at the bar
don't tell my bosses I said that and you
can just have a good time we're gonna be
hanging out with you guys recording the
show and then taking your draft on draft
questions to end of the show so get
those ready for gonna be a mobile first
question Conor from our guide am supa
explain the mutual benefit for the
Bengals and Joe Barrow being at the
Senior Bowl so I mean we've run through
this a couple times but I think it's
important to talk about it again because
people tend to get upset when we say
that he should be there I think the
biggest thing is you want to Jim naggy
said it well Friday you want to
jumpstart that relationship go ahead and
start building that camaraderie learning
the offense because while unlikely there
is a chance the Justin Herbert could
impress them enough in that week of
being hands-on together that he could
jump them could jump a jobber oh I'm not
saying it will happen I'm just saying
that is a possibility so if you want to
talk about the benefits it's getting
that relationship started now also you
know you want to compete all of us in
the media can sit here and say Joe
burrow should be the first quarterback
drafted last year it took Tyler murder
declared we were all saying to be Dwayne
Haskins
he was the third quarterback drafted so
I think it's easy in January to have a
quarterback board it can be very
different than the collective NFL could
be very different than individual NFL
teams so while Joe burrow looks like a
lock we joke about it all the time he is
for us definitely I think the Bengals
you know they are starting this
evaluation process naggy says it all
time the draft starts in Mobile so if
you're burrow you just gotta have that
competitive fire in you is probably like
man I wanna go down there and prove this
fool wrong and show the Bengals that
they need to draft me I think on the
other side of things Matt for burrow say
he's penciled in as the number one pick
already by the Bengals this is a player
that's been in college for five years
right now you kind of want to get a jump
start and learn what it's like working
with an NFL staff because naturally
those guys operate differently than
college guys so I think four and not all
the time because some worked at both
levels of football but some not Zach
Taylor's a younger guy you know I can't
speak to a lot about how his staff is
personally but I think when you look at
it for borough it's a nice opportunity
before you even enter the league
officially after draft night by getting
some time with them and just seeing hey
what are their expectations out of me
right now
what do they want to know from me what
do I you know what should I look to work
on when I don't get to spend time with
them so I think there's a lot of
advantages for each side as borough
takes this next step and the Bengals
hope that they have their franchise
quarterback of the future yeah and I
mean there's just a lot lot to gain but
I mean there is a risk I mean he we saw
the rib shot last night he seemed a
little bit tender at times so I I don't
know if we'll see him there if whether
he goes or not um he's still quarterback
one for me Billy he's my Mustafa so
that's a great name what would it cost
slash how realistic is it for the
Patriots to trade up to three and take
to it so to move from 23 to three oh my
gosh that is gonna take a lot I mean
whether you use the old Jimmy Johnson
draft trade value chart or the new age
one yet teams don't really use that
anymore on the chart three would be
worth twenty two hundred points New
England's pick at 23 is worth seven
sixty and the way it usually like so
future first-round picks are basically
worth the same because you kind of you'd
like you assume that teams are gonna
kind of stay stay flat so three ones
three ones is what it would take based
on the chart so
three ones and they don't have them I
mean obviously they don't have that they
are gonna get two threes as in terms of
comp picks this year for losing Trent
Brown and Trey flowers but even if you
did that like you're trading your next
three first-round picks basically well
what would what players would Matt
Patricia want that's they don't have any
players like really uh not like really
trying to be funny
the Patriots don't have any players they
joke you need every agent who else
trains the five Gilmore no no and on
defense like cava a noise for agent
Jimmy Collins the free agent and the
rest are just kind of dudes and they're
all old so you don't really need
something Michelle you have carry on
Johnson so you're not you're not trading
players no there's no player that goes
into the trade no so you can't do it
basically I mean three first-round picks
it would be something if that happened
and that's the quarterback fee who has
had two ankle injuries and a hip
fracture so if the problem is for me I'd
rather move back to five and take the
two twos in the draft yeah here's
something else I want to emphasize with
the Lions right now they're getting
fired after next year if they don't make
the playoffs so it doesn't matter how
many ones you have in two thousand
[ __ ] thirty you know what I mean
right yeah
that's the way they need to operate
right now where they need traffics now
for this year to be really good next
year so this isn't a long shot isn't a
Cleveland Browns let's get a ton of
draft picks and it's okay if we suck
which got everyone fired but yeah it's
it's a great idea and I know like
everyone we get hit with these all the
time like it's almost like there's a
conspiracy that the Patriots will
somehow get a great quarterback that
they might not you know none of the guys
that they flipped Garoppolo pressed it
they weren't early you know there
weren't first-round picks so maybe
Jairus diddums the future there
Gustavo Olguin outside of the
quarterbacks who benefited the most from
the national title game that we could go
through a list of ten players realistic
on this for me it I mean I say Simmons
played like Isaiah Simmons I just think
a lot of people hadn't seen him play yet
so it was like he that is who he is
I thought Patrick Queen and Clyde
Edwards Allaire were the two guys that
really stood out and we don't get a
chance to pat ourselves on the back a
lot in this business because we're more
wrong than right but I said it on the
Monday show my guy Richard Lawrence I
was like he's gonna make plays I thought
he had a really good game not not a
splashy game but a really good game
stopping the run so I thought Queen and
Edwards a layer though were the two
standouts outside of I mean Jamar chase
obviously but he's not draft eligible
and Derek Stingley junior he's not draft
eligible but of the eligible guys those
two were the ones that I really enjoyed
watching without a doubt i'm patrick
queen what a great game for him and a
low-key one because unfortunately they
had to get away from him as they started
just throwing the ball Travis etn played
pretty well I mean 15 carries 78 yards
he did over five over five yards to
carry against LSU I want to make that
very clear against LSU and he had five
catches so when ETM got the ball he was
really good last night I'm I love Travis
Eaton I just players with more power
last night than I did and I you know
I've told you guys all season I just
want to see him roll with some power
well he did so thank you for reading my
tweets Travis etn last question from
Aaron Yeats Raiders have three
third-round picks plus needs at wide
receiver and linebacker who are some
third round linebackers and receivers
who could be there now we Aaron if you
listen to the topic show we expect them
to go this position pretty early one in
the draft but I like this question
because too often we get stuck talking
about the top guys in the draft so round
three when you look at the where do you
wanna start let's start at linebacker
round three I like Jordan Brooks from
Texas tackle out we're gonna see him
next week he has the type of range and
the ability to play all three downs that
y'all need at the linebacker position so
I think he's definitely a fit
Logan Wilson from Wyoming another senior
bowl guy he's gonna run well Troy died
Evan Weaver prefers the big one yeah and
Troy dies a little bit of a smaller guy
so prime more of a coverage backer and
then a sleeper for you Hakeem Davis
gaither from appstate I think he looks
really really good at mobile as well so
those would be my linebackers receiver
if you start an around
three I think you probably start with
Michael Pittman jr. he could push up but
there are enough speed questions there
you can look at I'm scrolling through my
list so I apologize if you're watching
all the senior brokenness yeah Lynn
Bowden jr. I think it has a chance to go
around three chase Claypool Devon
Duvernay those are the receivers that I
have there Denzel Mims is probably
around four guy for me
same with Juan Jennings at Tennessee Van
Jefferson at Florida I think van
Jefferson could have a really good week
he's a good route runner but it's you
know there's a lot of depth at wide
receiver obviously the thing is with all
those players we just mentioned I could
poke five holes in them as a prospect so
when you look at Jerry Judy it's like a
body catches sometimes that's your only
complaint when you get down to Van
Jefferson you know or Denzel Mims you
got a lot more complaints about those
guys you're not getting that immediate
projection where do you think Colin
Johnson goes I think he goes day three
and a lot of people get on me because oh
I'm a Texas fan I think Colin Johnson
probably goes round five he is not gonna
run well I want to be proven wrong
I'll say this Colin when he's been on
the field at Texas has been amazing the
last two years he has barely been on the
field and I think he's probably a four
six guy in the 40 he's just gonna be
stiff he's six six he's 215 so in the
right scheme let him be a jump ball
player he's really good on the back
shoulder fade but he's just he's not
gonna be a threat outside the red zone
very much I don't think it's crazy at
all it's gonna be interesting to see how
the board shakes out with all of those
guys cuz I feel like what I like van so
much is that he his floor is so high to
me
like he knows how to get open and it's
just you don't have to debate it you
turn on the film the quarterback says
don't do him any favors and he knows how
to constantly get open and he has strong
hands if you know how to separate and
catch the ball you're probably going to
be productive at the next level
so that's why I think I like him the
best out of that crop and with Lynn he
could do so many different things and
he's really tough really tough I'm
excited for when we get to talk to him
on this show I think those are the two
out of that group that stand out the
most for me and Duvernay is interesting
I know you've been higher on Duvernay
than all of us on this show and he only
got better as the year went on he led
college football catches this year
that's that's a song forgotten and I
think he's gonna run really well I think
he has a big week of mobile he has the
right type of athleticism to show up
there all right that is our show don't
forget I will say next week this
schedule is gonna be a little different
shows will come out Tuesday morning
Wednesday morning Thursday morning yeah
because we'll be recording Monday night
Tuesday morning Wednesday night and then
if we have time I think we'll try to get
a Thursday show in there as well that'll
come out Friday morning so just make
sure you're surprised that way you get
yeah subscribe or get the BR app and
you'll get all the shows for Connors
Matt we'll be back with Melo Friday
morning having tons of fun here on stick
to football